uh welcome to this meeting of the
council I'm councelor Simon Dowling Vice
chair of babber District Council and
I'll be chairing this meeting today can
I first of all remind you of the usual
domestic Arrangements toilets are
situated outside the meeting room
opposite the stairs cold water is also
available in the breakout area outside
the meeting room if the fire alarm
should sound please leave the meeting
room by following the fire exit signs
and meet on the ipswitch toown football
club training pitch do not reenter the
building until you're told it is safe to
do so please switch off all mobile
phones or turn them to
silent I'd like to remind everyone
present that this meeting will be
broadcast live to the internet and will
be capable of repeated viewing the whole
of the meeting will be filmed except
where there are confidential or exempt
items if you make a representation to
the meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to being
filmed by entering this meeting you are
also consenting to being filmed by the
council and to the possible use of those
images and sound recordings for
webcasting Andor training
purposes the council members of the
public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully
excluded we'll now move to the agenda
item one apologies for
absence thank you chair we have received
apologies from councelor Lee Parker
councelor Elizabeth melesy councelor
Allison Owen councelor Brian Riley and
councel Jessica
Carter you councelor maybe would' like
to make a statement about councelor
Riley's abs
um thank you very much chairman um yes
uh very sadly councelor Riley's wife
Alice has died um I don't know how many
of you knew her um but I'm sure you will
join me in sending our condolences to
him um we were trying to work out how
long they'd been married um it was well
over 50 years it could have been 60 so
it's been a very long um and happy Union
thank
you thank you councelor mayy would you
convey our sincere sympathies and
condolences to councel Riley when you
see him next yes I will thank you thank
you item two Declaration of interests by
counselors are there any Declarations of
interest for today's business
please I see none thank you item three
uh to confirm the minutes of the meeting
held on the 21st of November 23 for
accuracy only are there any issues with
accuracy councilor
Holt yeah uh page 9 64.3 there's a
comment by myself it doesn't quite read
right from the end of line
two um it reads that um to South
cambrige distri Council and requested
all this is to happen that doesn't OB
makes sense um I think the gist of of my
point was that should uh this happen in
the future all members are consulted and
agree correspondence so whether we can
sort of amend that perhaps look back at
the minutes because what's written there
isn't right look back and make an
amendment to that I'd appreciate it
thank
you any other issues with
accuracy okay can I have a proposal for
the minutes please Council born thank
you
seconder councelor register thank you
very much so we'll take this vote by
show of hands all those in
favor
carried that is carried thank you very
much okay item four announcements from
the chair and the leader uh the chair
would like you to Note Paper BC
2330 which is a list of uh engagements
carried out by the
chair and I'd like to invite Council
award acting leader of the council to
make his announcements Council award
thank you
chairman I'm pleased to report babber
has provided living wellin winter grants
to 17 projects in the district the grant
was introduced last year to support vcfs
organizations in providing new
accessible spaces and activities or to
expand upon existing projects and to
provide warm spaces and help tackle
social isol ation I'd like to thank all
of the people that made pro projects
like these happen in our communities we
hope that this extra funding is helping
support the well-being of residents
during the colder months and helping
people to forge new connections within
their
communities it was good to see the newly
refurbished public toilets at JLA in
subur now open upgrading the toilets has
been something both we and sub Town
Council have been wanted to do for
several years so it's great to see these
plans come to life we committed over 50
,000 to the project and the building now
has new sinks toilets flooring tiles and
the outside has also been updated along
with our plans for a cafe and toilets at
BW Park we remain committed to improving
facilities in sub Town Center for
residents and
visitors at the last meeting of suff
public sector leaders a further 22
million pound has been pledged to tackle
the climate emergency and help the
county achieve its Net Zero Target the
money will be used on a variety of
projects to bring in low carbon
transport sustainable homes and cleaner
power for the county it will also be
used to support communities and
businesses with environmental
initiatives and finally I was delighted
to have been invited on last Saturday
along with more members councilors
mayoring Clover to caufield's Village of
the Year event to celebrate their being
named Salt's small village of the Year
there was a huge range of Village
organizations and clubs with stalls
showcasing what they do cotfield has
taken quite a lot of new housing but the
well-run and proactive Parish Council
has ensured that it has maximized the
availability of sill to improve
facilities for the village thank you
chairman thank you Council a ward um are
there any points of clarification on
those
announcements no thank you so item five
to receive notification of petitions in
accordance with Council procedure
rules nonone received chair thank you
item six questions by the public in
accordance with Council procedure
rules none received
chair thank
you item seven questions by counselors
in accordance with Council procedure
rules now we have uh questions on the
tabled papers which are available to you
in councelor Riley's absence his table
question will be deferred to February's
council meeting so I will ask councelor
halt to ask his question please thank
you
chair uh this question was originally
directed to the bab leaders which is
councelor Busby uh councilor s and
Council Ward but I think in the papers
is just a council woman um read the
proposed full Council debate on
governance structure review it was
agreed at full Council in March 22 to be
presented to the new Council after the
May 2023 elections I raised this at full
Council on the 18th of July in
2023 and as yet no one has come back to
members I note in the minutes from the
18th of July meeting that the chief exec
responded that a further review of the
government structure was agreed upon for
Council in the March
22 um debate and the officers would seek
to bring that debate before The
Constitution work group as soon as
possible nothing has been brought forth
to them six months on and there has been
no discussion at all with the
Constitution working group my question
is what is
happening thank you uh Council wall
would you like to respond please I
chairman yeah uh what is happening um to
be honest councel hold not a lot at the
moment the March 2022 council meeting
did agree that a further review of
governance Arrangements would be
undertaken after the elections in 20123
but it didn't specify a time frame I
would remind all members that we do
operate a cabinet model that is more
open and inclusive than it could be both
open and confidential items are
available to all members who can attend
and ask questions as leader in the past
and laterally as acting leader I have
exercised discretion on more than one
occasion to allow non-cabinet members to
make statements the most recent being
councelor Owen statement at the last
meeting we've also tried to make
improvements to Council meetings with
admittedly limited success but we will
continue to do this the Administration
has been very preoccupied with
finalizing its priorities for the next
three to four years pursuing several
initiatives such as progressing a local
listed building consent order signing up
to the court considered considerate
constructure scheme approving an
implementation plan for Ev
infrastructure and tackling the issues
raised by the social housing regulator
whilst also seeing part one of the JP
through to approval commitment of part
two and supplementary planning documents
and latterly of course setting the
budget for 2024 to
2025 fiddling with governance structures
while needing to address the pressing
budget problems could be construed as
Naval gazing however once we have a
permanent monitoring officer in place
then we can look forward to bringing
this work forward thank you
chairman thank you uh Council H would
you like to ask a supplementary would
sorry Council W that isn't good
enough this was a commitment made by the
previous administration of which 18
members were reelected and some sit in
this chamber today and it should be
honored it is undemocratic for it not to
have been put before this Council for
debate which is now 8 months since it
was
reelected the monitoring officer back in
2022 confirmed that it was a statutory
requirement that any change to
governance model would come into effect
at the annual council meeting can't
happen
before meaning that it is now I believe
very unlikely to come before all members
for decision to be implemented before
May
2024 the position we find ourselves in
today is a repeat of the 2022 scenario
where we find the cabinet model not
delivering Democratic process to members
of this chamber and our residents and I
quote as councelor Parker who isn't here
today previously said back in
2022 a cabinet system worked well with a
political majority but a committee
system was a better system overall I
like councelor Parker have been in
office for nine years and have
experienced both systems and I have to
agree with him we should not forget it
was proposed during the park and charges
debate of
2022 this is what drove members to have
the debate so I asked the question to
councilors Busby Ward and saw to commit
to that debate as previously agreed back
in
2022 by the end of March this year 2024
and let this Council decide its own
future and not the select
few thank you Council aard would you
like to respond yes I would I you said
um the cabinet model worked when there's
a uh political majority and obviously
when there was conservative political
majority so I think we we'd all want to
ask why is the conservative group so
eager to pursue this having seems to
suddenly changed their mind on on what
they would like the governor's model to
be but don't interrupt please members of
the public should and members here and
also the public should remember that the
leader cabinet model was agreed by a
conservative majority a majority Council
in 2016 and implemented by that same
Council in
2017 so this is a U-turn not for the
first time the conservative group has
pursued a U-turn so one has to ask no
policy no principle that they're willing
to sacrifice on the AL of
expediency and their desires of the
moment many years ago there was a
conservative leader who famously didn't
like u-turns times seem to changed a
lot thank you uh yes thank you councelor
halt I did not make this a political
issue and if if the councelor ward had
have listened to what I said I said
councelor Parker
was quoted as saying uh that the cabinet
system didn't work as a political
majority he too was a conservative at
the time and he too voted it in but
there are many members sitting here
today that aren't conservative members
who strongly opposed the cabinet model
councelor Holt point of order what is
the point of order please point of order
is Mr councilor Ward made a incorrect
statement that was a
conservative um issue it is not
political he's making it political
because it suits him but the members in
this chamber who are sitting opposite
there are more there today who voted to
have that debate than there are sitting
here okay Point M thank you very
much and committees uh 8A which is paper
BC
2331 the halfe report on Treasury
management 23 to
24 uh I'd like to invite councelor Haron
joint chair of the um audit committee to
introduce paper BC
2331 and to remove so to move
recommendations in the report
please yes thank you chair it's my
pleasure to do that I understand that
um uh Karen Watling and Alice deer will
be joining us remotely so um it's a bit
unusual but I just thought I'd make that
clear at the start but I will introduce
the paper and move it to the
vote uh this is a statut report required
by the C code of practice on Treasury
management it provide members with a
comprehensive update on Treasury
management activity for the period April
to September
23 in particular it gives an update on
compliance with the joint treasury
management strategy which was approved
by councils in February
23 this half yearly report was presented
to joint udit and standards committee
27th of November
23 that committee agreed that it be
recommended to babber council and that
the following be
noted babber District council's treasury
manage activity for the first six months
was in accordance with the approved
treasury management strategy and also
the council has complied with all the
treasury management indicators for this
period now the report contains appendix
a which provides the economic background
and a forecast of interest rate
movements appendix B um states that B's
borrowing has decreased by approximately
9 million during this period to 20
million at the period end this is mostly
due to the repayment of some short-term
borrowing termin there was a marginal
decrease in the level of long-term
borrowings but however this end balance
is still 95.5
million pendix c um deals with the
council's investment
activity uh we continue to hold 11
million in externally managed pooled
funds and have invested other surplus
funds with Market money funds short-term
deposits and and call
accounts
investment balances ranged from 125
million to 23 A5 million during this
period and has incre it decreased by
approximately three million at this
period
end section three um gives an update
regarding the council's non-t treasury
Holdings there are no changes to this
position that need to be flagged up to
members appendant D probably the most
appropriate one to go with this paper
um shows the indicators that the council
used to measure and manage its exposure
to treasury management
risks the council was fully compliant
with all these indicators during this
period and intend to remain
so now I'm chairman of this committee or
joint chair and as such I um make it my
ambition to bring out the very best of
all my reme members and to steer them in
a correct period in a correct
direction um but for the nuts and buls
things I do rely on the officers if
somebody wants to go in depth to any of
this what's in this
paper um I'm told that karum Watling is
our temporary 151 officer um for a
certain period and Alis de Greer who was
new to the um Council and I haven't met
yet has joined the team as well so um
you know I wish them both luck as new
members of the team and um look forward
to working with them so I'd soon move um
this paper and between us we will handle
any questions that um members like to
ask either tonight if we can between us
or um it can be done remotely after the
meeting if that is if that is EAS
inappropriate thank you
chairman thank you councelor Haron could
I have a seconder for the report
please you councelor register thank you
thank you very much okay we'll now move
to questions councelors may ask as many
questions as they wish however they must
be relevant to the subject under
discussion and must be a
question questions please councelor ma
um thank you chairman um as a point of
clarification really um could you remind
me or could our chief executive remind
me or put me in the picture of when we
actually decided that we would have
remote visitations from offices because
I thought they had to be within the
chamber um if not does that mean I can
have the night off and sit at home as
well thank you celor may no
unfortunately it doesn't so uh legally
you are all obliged to be in the chamber
officers are not obliged to be in the
chamber unfortunately Karen is unable to
be here from a medical perspective and
that's why we' taken the practical
decision that it works for her obviously
to be able to dial in to support the
council but not to be able to physically
get here because she's not unable to
because she's unable to do so today it
is something we're able to do it's
something that some councilors have
encouraged us to do more uh and we are I
suppose triing it to see how effective
it is we've done it in some committees
not others but it's certainly not
something that iully expect us to do on
a regular
basis thank
you supplementary neing yes
um
I think you just said because I'm can't
rewind it I think our chief executive
just said that um councilors have been
encouraging this remote officer link um
Well you certainly didn't ask me so who
has made that decision is it the cabinet
again thank you so no it's not uh and
certainly I've not consulted all
counselors on it it's a very pragmatic
thing your choice tonight was simply
either not to have the officer at all
which clearly is not preferable or have
dial in which makes a lot more sense uh
in this particular circumstance as I
said also it's not something we're
intend intending to do on a regular
basis but it is something that on
occasions councilors have suggested that
it would seem to a pragmatic approach uh
ra if the officers are unable to
attend thank you are there any questions
on the treasury management report
councelor
McLaren to be coming on S sh oh it is
now um on page 40 in appendix c um there
is a there's a comment about the funding
Circle performance which said bad debts
to be
recovered uh and I was just wondering I
can't find anything that tells me what
the level of the debt is and if there's
any time limit on us to recover those
debts thank
you
yes if I could refer this one to Karen
watland I'd be very grateful chairman
okay thank
you I'm afraid I don't know the detail
at this stage unless Alis you know we'll
have to revert back to you in writing on
this
issue uh yes I'm I'm sorry
I um yes I don't know the detail either
so uh I beg to um
back to committee on this in writing
here thank you okay so we'll come back
with an answer is that okay okay
councelor Ma um yes oh everybody's light
is on so I hope everyone can hear me so
some may wish to switch them off um yes
this actually um
refers to um councelor mcclaren's
question as well we've had this before
that there's been a deficit with funding
or with a funding Circle or perhaps we
should say bad debts I don't like that
wording but there we go um so obviously
the officers who are currently online
have not been briefed on this so could
someone also explain why the officers
have not been briefed on this historical
um bad debt thank
you Council
har big p I have a point of information
on this chair if I may okay let's have
that then um thank you chair uh yes page
40 does refer to a very tiny amount of
debt if you look at the
um pie chart up six pages further 34 we
have 0% uh investment in the funding
Circle when you drill down on table 2.15
on table 40 it does show um a tiny tiny
amount uh
039 uh million so that's what um 3
3,900 we're not talking about vast sums
here so I'm just trying to put this into
perspective and I can't say I'm terribly
surprised that officers with all respect
to Karen who are subbing for our
section1 officer would be unaware of
this because it is such a tiny part of
our investment that's the only point I
would make and I just offer that as as
information from experience okay thank
you Council hen did you want to respond
to the
question yes I was just going to say
chair that um Melissa rans would have
had all this at her fingertips wouldn't
she but um as we've had to bring um
somebody in as a section 151 officer at
quite short notice then um I think it's
best to wait everybody gets the head
round it it is a small amount and I am
aware of that but um people are entitled
to ask even if it's um 50 Quid aren't
they but um I will be we have our ex ORD
and standards meeting on Monday when I
will get to know the officers a bit
better and I can ask that they give um a
full briefing of of of of the debt which
I think is fair but it's obviously a
period when we're having to think on a
feet a little bit but um not for long
and um we hope that Melissa comes back
um post very quickly I would think thank
you okay thank you
okay another question counc M yes thank
you thank you chairman I lots of
questions tonight um this is first of
all a comment but then it is a question
I was always taught when learning about
money and whether it was on my parents'
knee or somewhere else that if looked
after the pennies the pents looked after
themselves so my question to councelor
MC is since he made a comment that such
a small amount when does he think that a
small amount doesn't matter when it's um
when it is dealing with Council
funding um which is ultimately taxpayers
money so what figure would he like to
put on it thank you you councelor mcro
I'm I'm not entirely sure whether she'll
be answering this question it's not my
responsibility I was offering this M's
information from experience however from
that experience I would suggest
that everything matters in the round but
the question um from councelor maber was
directed towards the officers non or
lack of knowledge on a particularly
small part of our portfolio and my point
was just to point out but it was quite
understandable that their focus was not
on this relatively small amount all
amounts are significant obviously
however focusing on the small tiny
amounts when we should be focusing on
the bigger picture seems to me count
productive and particularly when we're
looking at a whole treasury management
position and I think that's what's been
presented today so I have no fears or
worries concerning this because I've
examined the funding Circle through its
history over many years and I can recall
questions being raised when the
situation we were more exposed I happen
to believe for good reasons that our
exposure to the funding ccle was reduced
for very good reasons particularly in
that it was not providing an adequate
response a adequate return within our
treasury management and that's the
job thank you I think that's clear any
more questions on the report councelor
halt thank you uh pce
41 3.5 trading companies the table s
could the officers or councelor huren
please give an understanding to me about
the balance I believe was 9.16 Million
received uh which I assumes the payments
from
CCO um and interest payable 2.1 I just
want to ensure that um CCO are paying
their full interest payments to the
council and the council aren't
subsidizing CCO um I just want
clarification that what they're owed
they're paying and we're not getting a
false income because that debt is
outstanding thank you thank you Council
Haron chairman yes thank you um I will
refer that again to um Caren wling but I
did wonder if um councelor Busby might
be more appropriate but or even John
Ward um y let's try Karen first because
she needs to learn this anyway and then
the two counselors who are more involved
than me I think would be a good um
project
chairman okay Karen yeah mystone
situation is the lowely payments are
being made by CCO uh but the interest at
this current time is being acred um to
the accounts so it's amounts owing with
the expectation at this point in time
that those amounts will be received by
the
council thank you councilor W you like
to add anything uh yes there um for two
three years there are deferred payments
a small amount of deferred payments to
the councils so that CCO can retain that
for capital investment in the portfolio
but um and that's why we're acre those
and uh they will be repaid in full in
the fullness of
time okay Council
halt in such budgetary times where money
is very scarce how much are we talking
about how much extra pressure has that
put upon this Council and for you to
bring a budget to
us a balanced budget coun Ward I'll get
that precise figure for you I don't have
it at hand this this evening but I will
get it for you um in the next a
so okay thank you any other questions
yes I can see thank you Council
beer thank you Mr chairman um well I
think my question is somewhere to do in
page
41 but uh it's more that I want to know
the costum
um I hear what councelor MC just said
about um uh large amounts of money um
and what I want to know is that uh the
baber holding limited company babber
growth that is responsible for cork
slaying and if it is where can I find
the exact figures of this Coston because
as we all know this is a very very large
amount of money I can't say it here uh
but I think it comes under bab growth so
it should be shown somewhere perhap I'm
totally out of order Mr chairman and
doesn't refer in there I I I don't know
councelor Haron but uh baby growth that
is part of it I mean we could quote
hundreds of thousands of pounds but I
don't know what the figure is okay thank
you Council
har yes I think chair uh members have to
be aware this is an order of things that
has happened I think Council be are more
um concerned with what's actually going
on but I would think um councel Busby
would have a a a good hold on those
figures of what's of what's happening
there if I could refer to him or
councelor Ward who um a bit more up with
things than
myself councelor bosby uh thanks yes no
I don't is the answer um I don't think
bab growth has ever appeared in the in
the babber treasury management report um
it comes up as under a different heading
all together a different section and
figures will be
reported uh from B Holdings as the
holding company as you know B growth is
a joint venture between us and
Norse um and so yeah the figures aren't
included in here I don't believe unless
the the accounting experts can tell me
otherwise okay thank you yes follow up
thank you for that councelor Busby um
that that's quite helpful but could
could I have or could we have these
figures in time for the budget meeting
because I think it's important uh we are
talking of large figures and um I I
think we need to know if we're going to
cut this or try and pay for that that we
need to know what this is costing us
because that is a drain on our finances
you and I both know that thank you
Council I would say that's not relevant
to the report in hand which is a
treasury management report for the last
six months so I don't think we need to
pursue that any further okay are there
any other questions about the treasury
man answer of the amount I need to know
I don't know what it's costing us and as
a me elected member of this Council I
think I should be able to we've heard
that bber growth is not included in the
treasury management report okay so your
question isn't relevant to this item
which is about the treasury management
report it's a different question okay
could you in your good office ask that
this question be answer
I'm sure it will be shall we move on
chair can I just respond quickly the
amount will be in the capital program so
that's reported each quarter to cabinet
and it will also be showing in the
budget um that's going to full Council
in February in the capital program and
it will show the amount that's suspended
on the on the baby growth
limited excellent okay thank you is it a
question councelor Hal good please go
ahead sort
of I I do find it amazing that Council
can't answer the question with a figure
he is meant to be in control of our
budgetary figures he is meant to be
control control of the money and he
doesn't know how much we owe or how much
we have outstanding as does councel
Busby who equally I believe is a board
member and should have those answers so
I'm a little bit surprised concerned
that the man who's going to be
presenting our budget doesn't have a
clue councilor Ward would you like to
respond to this what can I just say
chair sorry um buby we understand that
the headquarters project is of a keen
interest and we understand that the
opposition uh are interested in the
figures and quite rightly too and we
will produce a report which analyzes the
whole project from start to finish
including the finances as soon as we've
got the the information to hand we're
still in the process of gathering
information as you can imagine it's a a
volatile circumstance at the moment
interest rates pass prices materials
getting things completed Etc so if we
produced a report at the moment it would
be wrong because we know it will change
but we guarantee that we will do that
for you the in as far as the budget's
concerned the figure that you need to
look at is the increase in interest
charges because of the extra loan that
we need to take out to complete the
project and that is in the budget
report okay thank you are there any
other questions
please okay we can now move to debate uh
councilors will be allowed to speak once
only for three minutes and this will be
Tim would anyone like to uh open the
debate
please okay good councelor Haren do you
wish to add anything at the
end
you you weren't very quick Off the Mark
councelor NE
unusually so Council chair chairman I am
so pleased that you understand that I'm
usually quick Off the Mark and on my
feet um it's probably because I'm trying
to remove my mask because I've got a bit
of a cough and I'm trying not to give it
to everyone else but it is not covid
you're all safe we'll keep leave that to
everyone else um I'm just going to
comment and say that I'm quite surprised
that nobody from the other side of the
pond here um wants to debate Finance or
the treasury report um is it because we
don't understand it and I'm using the
Royal we is it because we have no
interest in it Royal Wei or is it
because we just want to get on and go
home so that that is the question for
the debate we have managed to ask a few
questions from our side of the pond so I
leave it to everyone ask oh look hands
are coming up so hopefully there is some
debate coming thank you
chairman thank
you councelor mcro then councelor
register since I take that as a
rhetorical question and a former member
of audit and standards amongst other
committees can I give a
rhetorical
no I do take an interest thank
you thank you Council register
uh as a current member of joint audit
and standards I fully understand this
treasury report and I do not need to ask
questions at this
meeting thank
you anyone like to contri anyone else
like to
contribute thank you Council Haron
anything You' like to say at the
end thank you chairman I think um
Council register hit the nail right on
the head this is all fairly historic
boring stuff it's the facts of what we
done um it it's all in the tin if you
know I mean Anyone who reads the report
thoroughly um will see what we've done
they will see it's perfectly in order
and um I just remind to thank Council
Busby mcco and um Ward for helping me
out when some people strayed off the
paper chairman and um it's my pleasure
to move and SE a second thank you no we
we have a a proposed on second already
thank goodness uh thank you um I'll now
ask the assistant manager governance to
conduct the electronic vote on noting
the treasury management
report thank you chair that vote is now
in progress and members are voting on
recommendations 3.1 and
3.2
councelor mabery may I take your vote
please yes to vote against thank
you councelor beer may I take your vote
please yes I'm thank you very
much
thank you members that is 23 votes for
three against and one abstention thank
you so that motion is carried thank you
very
much okay item nine uh this is paper BC
2332 our plan for babber and I'd like to
invite councilor Ward to introduce the
paper and to move the recommendation in
the report
please thank you
chairman on behalf of councilor s and
Busby I'm pleased to introduce report BC
2332 the administration's plan for
babber our plan for Baba sets out our
vision approach and priorities to help
create a resilient more sustainable
future with and for all of our residents
and communities it will always be the
council's role to provide high quality
services but we are ambitious and want
to see our towns and communities really
Thrive we do however also recognize that
we need to be financially sound in the
challenging circumstances that all local
authorities are working
under as part of the process in addition
to the internal workshops and other
meetings that we have undertaken we
agreed that we would engage with our
communities businesses partners and
other stakeholders we made a particular
effort to engage with groups that
represent seldom heard voices in our
communities to ensure that we heard from
everyone
our message to the public was this is
what we think what do you think we
wanted people to tell us what they like
what they don't like what they think
we've missed and what matters most to
their Community we wanted to capture
wide ranging views from a diverse group
of people in short we wanted everyone to
help shape the future of their own
communities serious long-term change
takes time discussion and thought it
also requires us to listen and work with
our
communities this report describes how we
went about that engagement ment the
feedback we received and how we have
taken on board that feedback following
the engagement our plan for babber was
agreed by cabinet last month and now it
is presented to full Council to agree
its adoption our plan can be found in
appendix a and it gives our vision
Direction and accountability for what we
will deliver for our communities and
this is built on three themes a
revitalized improved environment a
thriving economy and resilient
communities I would like to propose the
recommendation three the council accepts
the cabinet's recommendation to adopt
our plan for babber and um obviously
here to ask answer questions but I think
I've spoken quite a lot this evening so
I'll be quite happy councelor s and
Buzby answer a lot of the questions as
well delited thank you chairman thank
you Council Ward can I have a seconder
for this paper please councelor s thank
you very
much right we'll move to questions again
councilors may ask as many questions as
they wish however they must be relevant
to the subject and be a question is that
councelor Reese
please okay right um on page 50
paragraph
4.4 it says there was some low response
rates from some areas including
businesses and the voluntary Community
social and Faith sector but that's on
and and sorry and ongoing commitment is
in place to continue the conversation
with these groups moving
forward does that mean that these groups
will be listened to when they object to
the parking
charges thank
you like to take that one well yeah um
very presumptious that they will object
to the parking charges um as we haven't
had the results from all the businesses
yet we can't possibly know what their
response will be um and hopefully we are
looking a bit beyond a narrow topic such
as c car parking charges to help
businesses thrive in the future there
are many other issues that we
can thank you other
questions councelor beer um thank you Mr
chairman well I was rather pleased to
hear uh councelor Ward say that he
wanted to engage with the public and
he's going to listen to the public you
know very well as much as I do that we
have managed to get nearly 5,000 people
signing the petition will you listen to
that against the compartment you're
shaking your head so in other words
you're saying no already um so you're
not going to listen to them then uh it
it's answers my whole question because I
don't believe that you're being honest
with us all okay uh councelor beer needs
to be a question please and it needs to
be relevant to the subject which is our
plan for B that that he just Shu his
head when I said you You' listen he
shook his head and said no in other
words I don't think it's relevant to the
the
topic I want to know whether you're
going to really listen to those people
that have taken the time to sign
petitions that those uh shopkeepers who
feel they're going to be hard done by
and all the other people that you're not
listening to at the moment you councelor
Buzby yeah uh the petition will come
forward to council and there will be a
full and Frank debate I should think on
that evening I'm sure we could probably
sell tickets for it um but that is the
opportunity that uh for us to for you to
put forward your views for us to listen
to what the public has said um I don't
know what the question was when the
5,000 people supposedly were asked
whether it included any alternatives or
whether it was just a case of would you
like keep free car parking in which case
can I put my name down for that as well
because everybody would like to have
free car parking but not at all cost
thank you Council
Clover thank you chair yeah in terms of
the first 30 minutes before I made that
decision thank
you thank you councelor
halt yeah back to the
paper um we've done this before and
looking at the numbers I mean 540
engagements total number responding 5 it
it's not good is it we just can't find a
way it seems to engage with our public
unless it's paring I go on there um but
it's it's it's not good that we are
presenting this with sear engagement
it's Ausable I don't know the answer to
it by the way because we have done it
before and we've got equally the same
sort of response it is very very
difficult we get criticized everyone
gets criticized as a district council
for not doing this not doing that when
we try to engage people just don't want
to know um unless they've got something
to complain about so it's very
disappointing um what I would say is the
headlines are great we need meet on the
bone as always and counselors who've
been here before we get the headlines
and we don't deliver the meat on the
bone councelor Hal I need a question
please will we ensure that we put the
meat on the bone and actually come
forward under the headline names and and
targets some deliverable programs thank
you Council
s um each of these um pillars will have
action plan
against them and you will note that at
the back of the plan we say that we will
be um evaluated and assessed against
those action plans so we are very very
uh
committed to actually having actionable
plans against all of these and we will
bring bringing these to um
Council thank you
um are you answering the same question
Council a ward please just wanted to
answer something with regard to the
engagement and the engagement numbers
and I take the point that Council hold
is making um I would invite Joe Hobs can
can you provide some further uh context
and and detail about that engagement
process because I know obviously you
you've been heavily involved with that
maybe U help to explain uh some of the
uh concerns that councelor Hol has yes
uh thank you to you chair uh yes the uh
numbers are um as stated in the papers
and um yes in general kind of terms of
some engagement that we have on some
subjects of the council they do look low
um we did make sure as we were going
through the engagement we checked in to
see what other councils um have managed
to achieve on this type of subject um on
their corporate plans and where they're
heading in terms of those high level um
picture plans and we did Benchmark well
throughout the um process and towards
the end um of the numbers we did achieve
it is a difficult subject for people to
engage with uh when you're proposing um
something very real to people's lives um
a development in the field next to their
house um other matters that have been
discussed in this chamber tonight it
elicits more of a reaction from people
and people feel more compelled to
respond because it's slightly more real
um strategy documents are slightly
harder to get a sense of um but as
Council of Saw did speak to there will
be delivery plans that identify what
that means in terms of actions um we uh
we also made sure that we uh try to get
a broad spread of responses from people
who we um hear from often and um people
that we hear from seldom heard voices
which was set out in the report as well
because it is so so important to make
sure that we have representative view um
across our our districts um but as I say
we did feel that um we uh we benchmarked
well compared to other councils who had
um carried out similar engagement on
similar plans and so we feel that we we
have a good representation of the views
of people who would um be likely to give
views um on this uh plan thank you chair
thank you any other questions on our
plan for babber councilor
McLaren thank you chair um well in this
chamber there's no such thing as a silly
question and I'm here to ask a question
or all those people out there in the
public that might be watching this
meeting
on page
58 of this paper we have Babor District
at a
glance uh and halfway down the page it
says
26.1% of adults classed as physically
inactive within our district and my
question is to council and to officers
what exactly are we going to do in a
practical way to reduce that number
thank you thank you
who's going to take that councel us
all um yes I I take uh councelor
McLaren's uh point this is um a large
proportion of adults classers physically
inactive um we are currently and did in
October launch um the Feelgood um
initiative which um has at its uh has
three
uh key areas one is Weight Management
one is uh getting people physically
active and one is helping people give up
smoking um people uh can self-refer
themselves to this um service or be
referred by their uh GP um it's early
days but we saw uh in
October um 200 plus people uh refer
themselves um this is uh
increasing uh over the months uh we also
run as you know a full range of services
um with our Leisure centers and uh we
are continuing to run a series of
programs to get people more physically
active um and I take the point there is
more that we can do and it is one of our
priority areas uh in the community's
area
thank you any more questions councel
halt yeah get back to what council s
said we do need projects deliverable
projects on on these items the one item
that I find missing or found surprising
that's missing is is from an economic
point of view there's nothing on there
that really to me drives economic growth
there's a small part of the bottom where
it says businesses also identify skills
and business support as a priority but
it's not one of our line uh drivers and
when you look at page 58 is Council
McLaren just said and the median house
prices are 10.6 times the annual res
resident earnings it just goes to show
we've discussed this in this chamber
before how we need to try and bring that
down we are in a low earning uh district
and yet there's nothing in there to
indicate to us that you are going to
prioritize the economic growth aspect
within B housing is fantastic we all
know that the housing of affordability
is something we we all want to strive
for so we can get people in their own
houses uh but I do find like the
transport we're very limited on what we
can do Council hold again I need a
question please question is and it was
there why have we got no reference to
economic growth in the headline numbers
one to five thank you councilor Ward um
you'll see councilor hold on page 60 one
of the three themes that I uh talked
about is uh uh described in more detail
thriving economy and there are a number
of items there which we are committed to
to help to build our economy and
particularly upskill and have better
paid and better skilled jobs
within it's on page if you look at page
60 I'm just explaining how how
it's okay don't interrupt while he's
talking
please the three themes are provided uh
in detail within the plan itself in
appendix a and as I said thriving
economy one of those and there are quite
a number of items listed under that that
go to address just the concerns you have
the concerns we all
have thank
you any more
questions councilor
Haren chairman yes thank you I'll see if
I can raise the level of um debate here
um Council award everything comes or
anybody everything comes at a price
doesn't it there's some serious
Ambitions here is it intended that this
project is self- financing through
growth
Prosperity where is the money coming
from and you know I would ask that
wouldn't I um cycle routes um Better
Health it worries me that not only the
council is not in a great financial
position going forward the nation itself
is not great High interest rates and
everything else the last few years um
the quality of living is um steadily
going down in my view could I have a
question please the question's already
been asked where's the money coming from
chairman I started off with that I'm
just trying to um fill out why I'm
asking how are we going to achieve this
where is the money coming from that is a
question and can we fulfill this
ambition be great but can we do it can
we afford it thank you Council
Ward well uh Council Haren you're quite
right these are challenging financial
times for all local authorities um and
we are doing our level best to make sure
that over the medium term this Council
has put on a sound financial footing
which is why uh we'll have this debate
when we come to discuss the budget next
month there are a number of measures
that we'll be taking not just for the
budget this year but also as soon as the
budget's over we will be looking at
exactly what we can do in further detail
to put it on a better Financial footing
so that we can afford the ambition here
um there'll be different ways that this
this Council will have to be run there's
no doubt about that because what we've
done in the past is not going to uh be
appropriate going forward in terms of
affordability but also a number of these
things can be done in partnership with
others and wouldn't necessarily require
uh huge investment from the council it's
just a matter of Designing uh the detail
to to meet these Ambitions and ensure
that we bring Partners along with us so
that there will be ways to to achieve it
it's not going to be easy I I'll admit
that and um but I can assure you that um
without we won't be able to do any of it
without having a sound financial basis
going forward and that is what we will
definitely do with the budget that we
will um put to Council next month and
then going forward beyond that thank
you
you Council mbery thank you chairman um
interesting um response from Council
award uh you're talking about our
partners um could you tell us all which
Partners actually have some money to
help us with all of this because I
didn't think we had any partners that
had lots of money at the moment thank
you it will depend on on uh individual
action plans delivery plans and with
which Partners we talk to and work with
um at this stage I don't have any of
that detail of course
not okay thank you any more questions on
our plan for
babber
yeah
yes any more questions good let's move
to debate uh councilors will be allow to
speak once for three minutes and this
will be timed councelor Holt I just want
to agree councel Haren I think he's he's
know it really um there is no money and
as members will know projects that we
have delivered have tended to be from
Grants schemes government schemes so the
idea is obviously to have the project of
them ready so that when those and if
those government grants and schemes come
available we can apply for them
hopefully gain the grant which is again
why come back to what I said to
councilor s we can narrow the projects
down so we ensure that we've got ready
things all typed up presentable ready to
apply for those grants because without
the grants Council H's quite right we've
got no money to do anything so um we
need to be as I say focused on this on
on what programs we want to deliver to
and bid for the money when it comes
around to the bidding thank you thank
you Council reg register then
councila um I think I've r
ideas are part of the problem we're
dealing with um the reason we have no
economic there's no emphasis and
economic growth is we want economies to
thrive not just have economic growth for
the sake of it um and of course there is
no money uh due to mismanagement from
Westminster
um looking at budgets it's really
obvious that the the majority of the
problems come from both the bank of
England and from the
government these are Ambitions these are
things we would that babber want to do
there are funding sources for some of
them for example if we want cycle tracks
cycle pars the government cut the money
from2 200 million to 50 million a year
which means that there is no money to go
around 100 over nearly 200 or 200 odd
local authorities to achieve cycle parts
that's not going to happen anymore and
it's not going to happen because the
government are have made
a stupid
decision the arrest of these each of
these will be funded if they can be from
various sources some of which will be
private some of which will be from
different funding sources but certainly
won't be from the government because
they haven't a clue how to manage the
[Music]
thank you Council
saw thank you chair um I take uh
councelor Holt's uh point and uh I think
uh we have been uh the council has been
successful in the past in getting grants
um we will obviously continue to do that
um but I think one of the key points uh
and Council a ward has referred to it is
that councils have to be smarter we can
and we have convened various
Partnerships to get things done because
we are closer to our residents than
perhaps any other public sector body we
deliver services on behalf of the um
National Health Service on behalf of
central government but we are totally um
up for working with with uh different
voluntary groups Community groups
NOS um the private sector and this is
what we are going to do um and we
believe that this is the future so yes
we will continue to look for Grants we
will continue to um put together
Partnerships to achieve these Ambitions
and um we are forward thinking we're not
stuck in the past and we will take um
bold moves
which I'm sure councelor H will be very
supportive
of thank you thank you any other
contributions please councelor Davis and
and councelor
mcco yeah thank you um I'm well aware of
the dire situation that we're in in
terms of the cost of living crisis and U
I think Council of register was pointed
out to the reasons why we're in such a
mess I want to look on the positive side
we have built up so much good work us as
counselors as an Administration over a
period of time so we're not starting
fresh we're building we're building on
all the good work that's been done by
our officers and exactly as Council saw
said by our partners in variety of ways
we're not starting a fresh what I would
also urge is that we encourage our
parish councils and mine's just as bad
as as everyone else is to use their seal
money they're getting it in we're having
to have housing people moan about the
housing but there's money coming in with
that we need that to help with the
infrastructure to help grow to help make
sure that we can get projects over the
ground that in turn brings funding from
other outside sources as well so yes
it's difficult we've got a really hard
grind ahead of us but you know let's
look on the bright side let's build on
what we've already
achieved thank you uh councilor
mcra thank you chair I think it's always
interesting to people say there's no
money that's a an over gross over
simplification there is money obviously
otherwise we wouldn't be here that's why
we do
budgets is how you use the money you've
got where you use it and that's what
we're talking about in terms of this uh
this particular plan i' just like to
point out that the chief executive has
made a very good point in the process of
discussing our budget process there are
two ways of squaring this circle is one
is to increase our income and the other
one is to reduce our costs those are the
fundamentals of any budget and the plan
is always going to have to take account
of the budget process it's a constant
ongoing thing and it's subject to
examination through scrutiny um the
treasury management through audit and
standards that's the process of a
council's operation and constantly
dragging up a single item um to raise a
point how however irrelevant it is to
the actual paper we're discussing misses
the point the point is what have we got
how are we going to use it and let's do
it step by step where it's relevant to
the paper so here this is a question
about a plan this is what the
administration proposes to do for the
next 3 to four
years it's a guide it will will not be
um old things and everything it's got
more work to be done and that's where
the points that Deborah has already
referred to will come in individual
plans for individual jobs so I think
just bear in mind a little patience
please thank you uh any other
contributions please councilor
ree um this is in response really to
councelor mcro um I find it difficult to
see this actually as a plan it still
seems to be a set of aspirations and
wishful thinking and some great ideas
but not really what I would describe a
plan as such thank you thank you thank
you any other contributions
please no okay so Council award do you
propose the paper is anything you'd like
to say at the
end um no I don't think anything else
thank you chairman
um I I take on board all of the the
comments councelor halt has has made and
um quite valid um councilor ree yes uh
it's not a detailed plan no it's it's a
vision and a set of priorities um plan
as as is probably a word that's
stretching a bit too much but we will be
looking at detailed delivery plans um to
underpin these these aspirations but um
as as a guiding set of guiding princi
principles uh a strategy for the next
three to four years it it sound and and
um detailed enough thank you thanks
Council
award okay I'll now ask the assistant
manager governance to conduct the
electronic vote on accepting our plan
for
babber thank you chair members that vote
is now in
progress Council mbery mayor take your
vote
please
I thank you thank
you thank you counselor councelor beer
may I take your
vote and councelor Hern may I take your
vote
please oh thank you thank you
sorry
thank you members that is 23 three votes
for one vote against and three
abstentions that's okay thank you that
is
carried right moving on to item 10 paper
BC
2333 the polling District review I'd
like to invite the Electoral
registration officer to introduce this
report thank you chairman um as you'll
know I wear multiple hats when I sit at
this Council chamber and one of them is
also the Electoral registration officer
you will also have seen reference within
the report to the acting returning
officer and that the Electoral return
sorry the Electoral registration officer
has consulted the acting returning
officer that's me looking in a mirror um
because I'm obliged to do so um I won't
you'll be pleased I'm sure go through
the lengthy appendices that you've got
within this report that set out the
various uh responses to the consultation
uh and any changes or rather any trial
changes uh that we are proposing we are
obliged to carry this exercise on a
regular basis we have done so
efficiently uh and wishing to do so
obviously ahead of uh the next elections
uh but if there are any individual
queries uh from Ward counselors in
relation to particular polling places uh
or polling stations I happy to try and
pick those up outside the meeting rather
than necessarily uh distract everybody
else with those
now I will ask obviously for a mve in a
second because I'm not able to do
that okay thank you could I have a
proposer for this report please
councelor Derek Davis and a seconder
thank you councelor
beer okay uh we do have the opportunity
for questions although as the chief
executive said individual Ward matters
might be better dealt with outside the
meeting uh councelor beer thank you Mr
chairman um we really
unbended this question was to pay a
compliment to the election staff um and
I'd like the chief um executive to pass
on my fs and I'm sure a lot of members
in this chamber will agree with me that
the um election officer who was worked
really very hard I forgotten his name
you know who I'm referring to um he he
really did it onehanded at times and the
staff that were around him with very
good and I can only speak from the
Poland stations in my ward but I always
go around them at election times
whatever the election is and they were
all very good and it was a credit to us
because they they weren't difficult with
the public they weren't difficult with
uh prospective counselors at the time
and I would just like you to compare to
them that uh it was very very hard going
at times but they handled it very very
well yes if you phras that as a question
yeah AB thank you councelor beer and I'm
more than happy to pass that on you will
also know uh Patrick who's the officer
you're referring to has joined us on
teams again very good reason why he's
not here tonight he's got covid and so
as you'll appreciate you won't want him
in the room um but I will he has heard
that comment to thank you ccil be but I
will pass on that thanks as
well thank you any other questions on
the polling District
review thank you we can move to debate
on this matter is there any anybody
who'd like to contribute to
debate councelor do
Davis yeah I just want to endorse what
councilor beer has said that's
it short and sweet thank you very much
councilor beer I will just make one
comment on the paper um and it's
regarding great cornard and I'm pleased
that you're want to stay the same but in
great cornard we do have a large
building Stevenson Center
which would cater for all the elections
that are held in great cornard we have
three polling stations at the moment
that includes that one and it's very
costly it's a way we could save some
money I want to try and help you achieve
some of your uh things that you've
outlined today and that's a small saving
that's the start but we don't need free
poing stations now in great cornard and
I most lik to a bit of criticism over it
but people can get poster votes and this
this is the answer if they feel they
can't get to it you can park in the
Stevenson Center you've got plenty of
rooms there you're not disrupting the
old school or the Rugby Club and uh I'd
just like you to bear that in mind thank
you thank
you any other
contributions okay thank you very much
so uh I'll now ask the assistant manager
governance to conduct the electronic
vote on the polling District's review
thank you chair members that vote is now
in
progress thank you Council M thank
you
thank you members that is uh 27 votes
for that's unanimous chair thank you
that is
carried moving on to item 11 uh paper BC
2334 decisions taken by the chief
executive under delegated powers in
accordance with part part two of The
Constitution I'd like to invite wearing
a different hat the chief executive to
introduce this report thank you chairman
uh again yes one of my other
responsibilities is where necessary uh
to take urgent decisions outside of
cabinet and Council meetings as you will
appreciate from a democratic persp
perspective I'm very loathed to do that
unless absolutely required to do so but
when it does happen I am obliged to then
report it back to for council at the
next available opportunity which is why
you had this report here for noting this
evening the Urgent decision on this
particular case as as you will be aware
government set aside funding for those
that were affected by the flooding from
Storm babbit H and what we needed to do
was put in place a policy uh in order to
make sure that that funding could flow
out of the door as quickly as possible
to those residents affected and so it
didn't seem appropriate to wait and
bring it forward to a cabinet or council
meeting at a later prescribed date and
obviously those uh residents
detrimentally affected having to wait
accordingly so heads the reason for
taking this as an urgent
decision okay thank you could I have a
proposal for this report
please thank you councilor
be not noted yeah to to accept it as
being noted and a seconder please
councelor mcra thank you very
much okay we can have questions on this
if you wish are there any questions
please
no questions thank you very much we
could have a
debate councelor ma yes I'm I'm going to
say something um I think there there's
nothing worse for a household than to
have a home flooded I just cannot
imagine it and when one thinks about all
the awful stuff that may have gone
through a house such as sewage so I
would just like to say that I I fully
approve of any funding that was given to
help the households and I would send my
best wishes to all the households
affected funnily enough I met one um I
going to tell you this tale but I've got
three minutes um she was she actually
sold me a Christmas tree and told I
can't tell you where can I tell you
where yes at wait Ros um and she
actually told me that she was there
selling Christmas trees and being very
happy
and she was very pleased that everyone
was enjoying Christmas but her house had
been flooded um by storm toet and she
was in temporary
accommodation um and I was just really
moved by the way that she was not
letting that get her down so my best
wishes and I'm sure everybody else here
agrees with me we send our best wishes
to those who were affected thank you
thank you any other contributions please
councilor
yeah I'd just like to answer chief chief
I emailed him back in November uh about
the suff resilience group and the idea
of having a collective link where all
the parishes and all the communities
could access one link because one thing
that came out during the time was that
certain individuals residents were
struggling to find information whether
it be flooding or other issues and the
idea of having the suff at resilience
group have one link with all that
information available so residents can
just dial into it and get up toate
information with something thing I
thought that would be very useful I
don't know if the chief chief ex's got
an update on that I don't at this stage
personally but I'm happy to take their
way and double check we did an initial
if you pardon the PD wash up um
following the flooding uh back I think
in November in terms of any immediate
actions we could take and we will do a
further uh review uh once we are through
this winter season to make sure we learn
all the lessons uh through this exercise
because uh depressingly I suspect WEA of
this nature is with us to
stay Thank you any other contributions
Council ree thank you chairman sorry
this might actually be a question is
that permitted still well it depends how
you phrase
it can
imagine I sorry I haven't read this um
appendix in great detail but this is a
question really given that um uh the
district excuse me is largely Rural and
a lot of our Farmers have been severely
affected by the
um to what extent do they receive any
help because you know there there have
been potatoes rotting in fields um U
Machinery getting stuck um all sorts of
things going wrong for the farmers
trying to get harvest in for the last
few months I'm just wondering what
provision there is for them because I
don't know I probably would find it if
I'd read it accurately thank you I don't
you chairman I I don't think you would
have found it through this um this is
primarily in relation to the uh 500 P
which FS incredibly stingy it's not our
money it's government's money um paid
directly to households affected yeah
there are effectively three schemes one
for householders one for future
resilience uh so me again measures that
households can take flood boards and
such like um and then one to support
businesses but I'll take away the
question because I'm not sure whether
that has extended to the kind of impact
that farmers would have experienced as
opposed to if purely a building being
impacted as you say given the rural
nature of our area and the financial
impact for farmers and you only have to
drive around the the district and see
the amount of fields that are under
water still and probably will stay under
water for several months thank you may I
come back to that thank you um that's
why I asked because it referred to
businesses oh sorry that's why I asked
because it did refer to businesses
thanks very much thank you any other
contributions to debate
please okay thank you uh so I'll now ask
the assistant manager governance to
conduct the electronic vote on noting
this
report thank you members that vote is
now in progress for
you thank you councilor mbery thank
you
thank
councelor Osborne are
you may
I may I take your vote verbally
please four thank you
uh thank you chair that is uh 27 votes
for that's carried thank you that is
carried item 12 hold on we're almost
there councelor appointments uh the
appointments are listed on the agenda
but I do have one Amendment which is
under the suffk enhanced bus partnership
to delete Council Lee Jameson and insert
councelor Tim
register are there any further changes
to appointment
please okay can I please have a proposer
for these
appointments councelor Busby thank you
and a second councelor Haron thank you
and I'll ask the assistant manager
governance to conduct the vote on this
item thank you
members that vote is now in progress for
you to
vote thank you councilor
m councelor b may take your
vote
thank you members that is uh 20 votes
for
uh
20 20 sorry 20 votes for votes
for one vote against and one abstention
okay thank you that is
carried item 13 motions on
notice there there are no motions
unnoticed thank you chair thank you uh
so that's our yes councelor
Busby yes chair I I meant to bring it up
at the at the right time which is the
treasury management report I was a bit
concerned that three people voted
against the treasury management report
which seemed to indicate that they
didn't understand it is it possible that
we could arrange some training for those
three people
please thank you I'm sure that'll be
welcomed by
everybody um councelor
halt just like to congratulate you chair
on handling the meeting I thought you
done a very good job thank you thank you
very much thank
you okay uh the next meeting is on
Tuesday the 20th of February 24 at 5:30
p.m. I declare this meeting
closed